- [Voiceover] We're back,
and we're sitting on stools.
(laughing) Tonight we're
joined by the cast of
what I consider to be the
funniest show on television,
Silicon Valley.
Please welcome Zach
Woods, Thomas Middleditch,
Kumail Nanijani, and Amanda Crew.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat jazz music)
Wow you're wearing the pied piper jackets.
- [Voiceover] Everyone
on stage is wearing wool.
- [Voiceover] You're in an
incredibly hot auditorium
wearing wool, and those look awful.
They look absolutely terrible.
- [Voiceover] Thank you so much.
- They're also incredibly hot,
so I smell like Ellis Island.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Now wait,
you've maintained that because
there's an episode of the show obviously
where these jackets debut and
they become chick magnets,
you have maintained that you
think you look pretty good
in this jacket in real life.
- [Voiceover] I definitely
like this jacket,
and objectively I know it's an ugly thing,
but I love it.
(everyone laughing)
Just so you know it's
got everything for it.
Rats.
- [Host] Rats?
- [Voiceover] Upon the sleeve.
- [Voiceover] What number are we?
We're number one.
(audience clapping and cheering)
You'll note that every
letter is a different color?
- [Host] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] It's truly terrible.
- [Host] It's the worst idea ever.
If you've ever had a fantasy
about being a NASCAR,
you're doing it right now.
- [Voiceover] Well, it's
kind of -- I think --
based on our terrible
decision to make jackets
for ourselves in real life,
we all decided that it
would be a pretty cool thing
if the cast like worse
jackets for ourselves,
wore them around the lot and
we'd call ourselves The
Rude Boys' Lot on the studio
Sony Pictures Lot,
and we think the writers were like,
"Not on our watch."
(audience laughing)
But put this into the show.
- [Host] Just to humiliate
you as much as possible.
- [Voiceover] To take us down a peg.
- [Voiceover] The quality of ours is like
made out of sweatshirt,
and then this is like silk line.
We made shitty ones, they
make really nices ones.
- [Host] Those are gorgeous though.
Congratulations.